Je n'ai pas envie de me laisser deviner qu'il a
fait quelque chose de fou, montrez-moi encore Je
veux te casser le cou bien le film
était bien
Nebraska Williams Esquire c'est Lynch
supprime Wow je ne pense pas qu'il croyait
allez bébé j'ai eu une course-  avec un
espace là-dedans,
le reste d'entre nous se concentre sur c'est la chose
qui a tué mon homme les extraterrestres les
prédateurs exploitent la faiblesse suit sa
proie mais semblent encore une fois en profiter
ce n'est pas un prédateur qui est un
chasseur sportif eh bien nous avons pris un vote prédateurs
plus cool ouais  vous avez un plan X
nigra avec le SSPT, puis une équipe qui est
mentale,
vous êtes fou, lancez-vous,
mais vite et vous baisez, leur idée
du tourisme a
compris quelque chose, je pense que nous
allons mourir
juste en le signalant à un grand garçon, un chasseur
qu'il a amené  ses chiens avec moi
le prédateur seulement dans les théâtres
vous